i was reading about socrates today and i
was reading about
socrates trial you know he was tried by
the athenians for
corrupting for for failing to worship
the correct
gods and corrupting the youth of athens
by like teaching them stuff and asking
them questions you know which is a great
way to corrupt people and
um so he knew the trial was coming
and athens wasn't a very big place only
had about 25 000 people everybody knew
everybody everybody knew who the
powerful guys were and
everybody including socrates knew that
the trial was a warning to like get out
of town right
so we're going to put you on trial in
six months and the potential penalty is
death got that it's like so
so socrates had a chat with his
compatriots and they
were contemplating fair means and foul
to
set up a defense for him so that he
could or to leave
so that he could not be tried and put to
death and
he decided that he wasn't going to do
that and he also decided that he wasn't
going to even think about his defense
and
he said why this is quite an interesting
thing
he said why he told one of his friends
that he had this voice in his head
a demon a spirit something like that
um that he always listened to and that
that was one of the reasons he was
different from other people because he
always listened to this thing
it didn't tell him what to do but it
told him what not to do he'd always told
him what not to do
and if it told him not to do something
then he didn't do it if he was speaking
and the little voice came up and said
no then he shut up and he tried to say
something else
and he was very emphatic about this and
he said that when he tried to
plan to evade the trial or even to mount
his own defense
the voice came up and said no
don't bother with it and he thought well
what what
what the hell do you mean by that like
there's a trial coming and i'm gonna be
put to death
and well he eventually concluded that he
was an old guy
you know the next 10 years he was in his
70s perhaps the next 10 years weren't
going to be that great for him
he got a chance maybe the gods were
giving him a chance just to bow out you
know to put his affairs in order to say
goodbye to everyone to avoid that
last descent into catastrophe which
might have been particularly painful for
a philosopher and to
and to walk off the world on his own
terms
something like that
the point i'm making with that is that
socrates attended to this internal voice
that at least told him what not to do
and then he didn't do it and of course
socrates was a very remarkable man and
we still hear about him today and we
know that he existed and all of those
things